20:17 is in full gear which means more  free games with gold or on the way I'm  Tony this is a GameSpot news update and  this is your February lineup  first up Xbox one is getting the crazy  co-op game lovers in a dangerous  space-time all month long it's also  getting racing sem project cars from  February 16th through March 15th the  Xbox 360 is getting classic adventure  game Monkey Island 2 special edition  from February 1st through the 15th and  the action-packed Star Wars The Force  Unleashed from February 16th through the  28th and remembered those 360 games are  also playable on Xbox one the new games  with gold are coming soon but you still  have time to grab some of January's  titles including killer instinct season  2 on Xbox one which is available through  February 15th  so which games are you picking up let me  know in the comments or on twitter at  chaingun Pope and for all the latest  xbox news don't forget to subscribe